not serious for some people but it's
deadly serious
for others so i'll stop there and that's
kind of the overview
no that's exactly that's incredibly
helpful tony and really my
follow-up is because i think that
the virus has this disparate impact as
you've described
there's some issues that the public
debate now that would be really helpful
if you could help
clear off i mean one would be there is
this
discussion about whether a rise in total
u.s cases is a result of testing alone
as opposed to the disease progressing
and two is should we take comfort the
death rates are declining which they are
even as infection rates increase and
then this recent discussion about the
ability of the the virus to spread
through aerosolized form versus the
droplets and i just
if you could just those issues keep have
been coming up regularly if
there'd be if you'd be able to help us
understand what
the science shows us yeah okay
so first hang on i just i want to write
down your questions john
okay so sorry i was distracted with that
so
the first question is is this just
an increase because of testing versus an
increase well there's no doubt
that it's both i mean obviously the more
you test the more you're going to pick
up so increase in testing
is going to give you increases but there
is no doubt that there are more
infections
and we know that because the percentage
of cases
of the the cases that are tested that
are positive is
increasing therefore unequivocally
you're seeing
truly more new cases in addition we're
seeing
now more hospitalizations which lag
behind infections and we're starting and
we'll see
though not as much as we've seen very
likely more deaths
so clearly there are more infections the
second question
is i think you you hit it which is
really should we take comfort that death
rates are declining
okay so we've got to be careful because
remember
the big spike in the death rates that we
saw was the terrible situation
that they went through in new york city
metropolitan area
in situations in chicago in new orleans
and detroit
and that death rate happily is going
way way down what will happen is that
we will likely see some more deaths as
people get hospitalized
but i doubt john that it's going to go
up to the extent
that we've seen before mostly for a
couple of reasons
one is that if you look at the age range
of the individuals who are getting
infected now as opposed to early on
a few months ago it's about a decade to
a decade and a half
younger so even if young people which
some do
get sick enough to get hospitalized
it is highly unlikely that the death
rate among them
are going to be at the level of the
death rate of what we saw
in the real core of the explosion that
we saw in the northeastern
part of the country and then the last
really the other
question has been in the debate is the
extent to which the virus is transmitted
through aerosol
yeah that is still debatable john
in fact two minutes before i came in i
just read a summary
analysis of it and i there's almost
certainly that there is a degree of
aerosol
occurrence the degree of transmission
aerosol wise is very unclear most people
think it is not the dominant modality of
transmission
but the definitive proof has not been
put i don't think it's dominant i think
it actually occurs and for those
listening to know the difference
is that droplet type of transmission
rarely goes beyond six feet so if you
cough sneeze or even talk
a droplet would tend to drop to the
ground which is the reason for the six
feet uh limit that we talk about about
staying away
when you have aerosol it's in a droplet
that's less than five micrometers which
means
it has the capability of floating around
so you would expect
that it does have the capability not
only temporally of floating around
but getting behind the mask around the
mask or in the mask
so that's what they talk about with
aerosol i mean that's very helpful
and i'll turn this over to mo now for
the next question
hey dr fauci thanks again for joining us
today uh let's turn to the response a
little bit
now um you know as we've already talked
about
the the disease has hit the united
states harder than many other
nations around the world and as you
talked about it's not entirely
just because of of testing
and so starting big picture first you
know
how much of that do you think has to do
with
some of the nations that have dealt with
this maybe a little bit more effectively
have had more of a coordinated
national response whereas we have opted
for more of a
state-based or local or regional
response here in the united states
is that part of the disparity can we
even have a coordinated national
response yeah
the united states you know uh mo it's
it's always easy to
look back and say if we had done this
would it have been different i mean
that's always where you know and that
will happen
when this is over and people will i'm
sure analyze it every
which way some of the things that i
believe
have an impact on the differences
and i don't think we can fully explain
it is that in europe for example
and in some of the asian countries when
they
shut down essentially locked down
they locked down to the tune of about 90
90 plus
percent they really lock down we have a
very large and a very heterogeneous
country
with different risks in different places
geographically
and demographically and in reality even
though we locked down
considerably we only locked down the
estimate
as somewhere around 50 55 percent or so
so when we had the outbreak and in
europe
they went up they peaked and then they
came right down
to baseline they they really did go down
from thousands of infections
to handfuls or so of infections whereas
in the united states if you look at our
curve
for better or worse we went up
we peaked we came down and we never
really came all the way down to baseline
we stayed around 20 000
a day of new cases until the most recent
surge
when we went to 30 then 40 and 50
and then 60. so the issue is
we never got down to the baseline so
that when you started to open
up you had relatively few amounts of
infections to deal with
whereas when we opened up now you're
seeing the surge the reason for that
a complicated mo and there there are
many the
issue of how one does a response
you know we live in a country that from
its founding
had a federalist bent to it where there
were states
that had the independent right and and
capability
of doing things their own way in many
respects
that works to our advantage in other
situations
possibly that really was a little bit of
a disadvantage here
very difficult to make a definitive
comment about the contribution
that that paid for the difference
between what we see here and what we see
in europe
okay i'm going to toss it over to john
we all have so many more questions
we're going to try to get through john
and mine as quickly as possible before
we go to the students and this is just a
reminder to the students
uh you can still continue to submit your
questions using the q a tab at the
bottom of your zoom screen
great um tony speaking of the schools
and
students um you know many schools around
the country are announcing their
guidance we
for the fall we have at georgetown but
um
but just yesterday the la county and the
san diego county public schools
announced that they would be
online for the entire fall
the president many others have been
talking about
reopening schools full reopening as
quickly as possible
the cdc's issued guidance
describing steps that schools can take
to open safely
i guess what i'd love for you to do is
step back and just help us
think about how should how should
schools approach the upcoming academic
year
and if you could clarify what we know
now about the risks of children
teenagers and young adults across that
whole
age cycle from k-12 through higher ed
and and the risk that they present to
among themselves but also with teachers
staffs and their families is
what's the right way to think about this
as schools go forward
okay so let's uh john for clarity let's
just talk about
you know elementary uh middle high
school and not
university because there are major
differences there
and we could get into universities later
but i think people
are much more focused on school so i i
start off
with a general principle and then work
your way
towards the operational aspects and the
exceptions so as a general
principle we should try as best
as possible to keep the children in
school
for the reasons that the unintended
downstream ripple effect consequences
of keeping the kids out of school and
the impact
on working families and on other aspects
of society
can be profound not to mention the
negative
effect on the children so as a principle
we should try
as the default to get the kids to stay
in school
however that's going to vary from where
you are in the country and what the
dynamics
of the outbreak are in your particular
region
so that's the reason why although the
fundamental principle
is there the one other guiding principle
that
is overriding is the safety and the
welfare of the children
and the safety and the welfare of the
teachers
so you've got to take that into
consideration so if you're in the part
of a country where the dynamics of the
outbreak
are really minimal if at all then
there's no problem
at all in getting back if you're in a
situation where you're in
outbreak mode then you leave it up
to the local individuals as you've said
in certain california schools
certain florida schools of making a
decision
based on the judgment of making sure
that safety of the children and safety
of the teachers
are paramount so you guide the principle
let's try and get them open to the
extent that we can
but let's take a look at the dynamics of
the infection
in the area that you're in thanks tony
thank you
this maybe is a little bit more um less
about the response
from the government more about the
response from citizens
look yeah i'm glad you're here and i'm
glad you're speaking out
and i'm glad that you are giving
students a chance to talk with you
because a lot of people are confused
right now about the state of the
pandemic and what they should be doing
my wife and i every night sit down and
try to figure out what we're allowed to
do with our kids
based on we're comparing different news
stories we've read or different pieces
of guidance that we've picked up
and i think a lot of the confusion can
probably be attributed to three main
uh three main issues one the evolving
nature
of the pandemic has resulted in more
information
and new information and involving
guidance
two a growing body of deliberate
misinformation and disinformation that's
being spread
much of it online and three
the polarization and growing
politicization
of the discussion of the pandemic right
i mean just
even this past weekend the white house
pointing to some of your previous
comments
uh in order to question some of the
guidance so my question
is this given all of that misinformation
disinformation evolving guidance
uh increased politics in the
conversation how do people synthesize
all this information in order to make
the right decisions
how do they know who to trust
uh mo that's a good question and
it's it's difficult you know
to um give you a definitive answer
except that for the most part i believe
for the most part you can trust
respected medical authorities
you know i believe i'm one of them so i
think you can trust me
but i i would stick with respected
medical authorities
who have a track record of telling
the truth who have a track record of
giving information
and policy and recommendations based on
scientific evidence and good data
so if i were to give advice to
you and your family and your friends of
your family
i would say that's the safest bet to do
to listen to the recommendations from
that category of people but it's
entirely understandable
how the public can get mixed messages
and then get a bit confused
about what they should do let me let me
ask one quick follow-up before tossing
it
uh back to john um you just
mentioned data and you know there was a
story that broke
literally moments before we convened
here today about
um bypassing that data collection will
now
bypass the cdc and go straight to hhs
and i'm wondering if you had any
thoughts on that sort of late breaking
news
no i mo one of the bad ideas about
commenting on late breaking news that
you didn't read
that's a surefire way to shoot yourself
in the foot i think i'll pass on that
one
fair enough fair enough all right we're
gonna go to john
and then after that uh write to student
questions
um which will be probably better than
any of any of john or my question
absolutely and and i and i think my last
question as we start to queue up the
students tony really is
um and i know we asked a lot of
questions but it really does
so far get to the complexity of this
experience the country is going through
but
you know most of the people on this uh
webinar
are students and they're our young
adults
and i guess as we start to bring people
on i'd love
to ask you to say given what we know now
given everything we've talked about
what what is your message to young
people young adults
um teenagers um you know as more states
open up some are pausing but really
focusing on so what are the risks
and the responsibilities of young people
as we think as
we approach the pandemic where we are
right now given what we know
well thank you for that question john i
was hoping someone
asked it because i think it's key
it's really key to what is going on
right now
with the resurgences that we're seeing
in some of the southern states
and and i say this with
some trepidation because i don't want to
seem preachy about it
but since right now if you look at
what's going
on in the country that the infections
are among young people
very likely contributed at least in part
to what you're seeing
on tv of young people gathering at bars
crowded places congregating many without
masks
there is an understandable
situation where a young person could say
you know statistically
the chances of my getting into trouble
by getting infected are
much smaller than an elderly person and
a person
with an underlying condition and since i
as a young person
and really quite healthy it doesn't
matter to me
i'd rather be there sipping my margarita
at a bar in a crowd well to me that's
understandable i'm not blaming that
that's innocent however
what they need to understand is that
given
the nature of this outbreak even if you
get
infected and have no symptoms at all
and never get sick you are inadvertently
propagating the pandemic you are part of
the problem
and not the solution because by
propagating the pandemic
i mean it may not matter to you
because you probably are not going to
get any symptoms but the chances are
you're going to infect someone
who then will infect someone who then
will be a vulnerable person
who can get sick who can get
hospitalized
who could even die so not only are you
propagating
the outbreak but you're actually putting
other people in danger
so i would hope you could appeal to the
young people to not only take
the individual personal responsibility
but think about your societal
responsibility
and that's what i mean when i say we're
all in this
together everybody has a place
and a role in getting this outbreak
under control and you're not caring
whether you get infected or not
is not a good way to get the outbreak
under control
to get it under control means you don't
let yourself get infected
and you don't spread to anybody else and
again i i say that with some trepidation
because
i'm not blaming anyone and i think
people do this
innocently they don't mean to be part of
the problem
but inadvertently they are a part of the
problem and that's the message
we've got to get across thank you tony
thank you very much and um so maybe i'll
turn this back to mo
uh because we're gonna be able to bring
in some student questions here um
um next so let me do that um all right
we've got a lot of questions so
uh dr fauci we're gonna try to get
through them
as many of them as we can
our staff will notify students
when we are ready are getting close to
being ready
to call on you when we do make sure you
are as we say in the business broadcast
ready
because you're going to be up on screen
asking dr fauci
uh your question directly when we call
you make sure you introduce yourself
tell us who you are
uh where you're zooming in from your
school year field of study
so that dr fauci has a little bit of
context and so with that
our first question comes from varsha
uh manan marsha tell us uh introduce
yourself
my fauci thank you for coming to speak
with us today
um my name is varsha and i am a senior
in the sfs
school foreign service majoring in
international political economy
and um i'm currently zooming in from
plano texas
so i'm in a covered hot spot at the
moment and
um i guess my question has to do with
like what young people can do to
contribute to de-politicizing this
pandemic
um because i feel like a lot of this
pandemic has been kind of
been like controlled or like been
impacted by politics so i was just
wondering what young people can do to
kind of make it more about science and
less about politics
well i mean young i mean obviously that
that's appear appears to be a simple
question but it's
it's a complicated situation that you're
asking about
it's it's very tough for young people to
have an impact on deep politicization
except
by not being part of the politicization
in other words this is a
pandemic keep reminding yourself and
your peers
that this is something in which it
doesn't matter
who you are or what you are your
republican democrat any anybody else
we're all in this together and the way
you can
do that is by fortifying each other
in what you can do to essentially be
part of what i just said
protect yourself the best thing you
could do
is protect yourself and fortify
your colleagues in their attempts
hopefully successfully to protect
themselves from getting infected
the way to the way to squish squash out
an outbreak
is to have not anybody get infected so
you're not getting infected
marcia is a big contribution
to what we need to do so hang in there
do your thing
and don't get involved in any of the
political nonsense
that's a waste of time and a distraction
all right thanks for the question marcia
next up we've got
john figg excuse me if i'm
mispronouncing any of the names but john
introduce yourself to dr funji hi dr
crouchy
i'm john figgy and i'm
coming to you from bryn mawr
pennsylvania i'm a
soft a rising junior in the uh
school of foreign service i'm a global
business major
and my question was um what kind of
studies can we uh
can we do right now in the middle of the
pandemic uh
about masks and uh transmission of the
disease
um or are we just relying on uh
anecdotal evidence because we're not
able to do those
kinds of studies right now you know
that's a good question
uh john um right now if you look at the
meta-analyses and there are pretty good
studies
of meta-analyses about the efficacy of
masks
both for preventing you from infecting
someone else as well as
someone else infecting you are pretty
good
i would not want to do a randomized
controlled study because that would be
having people not wear masks and see if
they do better
right now i'm convinced enough in the
summation
and the uh i would say the totality
of the data that has been analyzed by
meta-analysis
that i'm convinced that the benefit of
wearing a mask
clearly is there and is better than not
wearing a mask
and i think to do this study would be
kind of difficult to do
because then you'd have to tell people
not to wear masks
and i'm not about to tell them that
all right john thanks for the question
next up we've got
uh caleb caleb yep caleb go ahead and
introduce yourself
hi thank you dr faunchi um i am caleb
i am a senior in the school of foreign
service currently zooming in from
washington d.c
my question is on the world health
organization so the trump administration
has criticized
the wt who and has also
submitted plans to withdraw from the
organization um how do you believe
the who has done in terms of
coordinating a global response to the
pandemic
and what are your thoughts to the plans
for withdrawing
well uh caleb i mean obviously this is a
complicated situation
uh i can tell you that i've been dealing
with the who
heavily not just peripherally for the
last
40 years very intensively in the last
36 years since i've been director of the
national institute of allergy infectious
diseases
they are an imperfect organization
they have made mistakes but i would like
to see
the mistakes corrected and for them to
be much
more in line with the kinds of things
that we need
there are some very good people at
the who including the director general
who i know very well and i have a lot of
colleagues
that i've interacted with over the years
so i hope this kind of tension between
the united states and the whole somehow
or other
ultimately gets settled in a favorable
way
because the world does need
a wh o for outbreaks like this
and even for the general health of the
globe to coordinate it
so i hope this thing gets resolved in a
way
that we find that's all favorable
caleb thanks for the question next up
we've got andrea hobby andrea go ahead
and introduce yourself
hello my name's andrea i'm from bethesda
maryland i'm a current graduate student
epidemiology at georgetown university
and my question is um dr about you what
is the best way i guess
maybe for policy solutions to defray the
cost of
testing as schools reopen cause i know a
lot of schools they would like to do
testing for like all students when they
come back and it's just an enormous cost
in addition to the current like
financial losses they're having
well you know i i don't really have a
good answer for that because that's
i mean when i start talking about money
and costs i'm out of my area
you want to talk about other things i'd
be happy to do it you know
a lot of the testing can actually be
free of cost
uh so i'm depending upon where you are
and what you're doing so there are many
things
that have to do with testing and even
treatment of covert that really is
without course
since i'm not as familiar with it andre
as
as i'd like to be i would refrain from
making comments because
as you know that often gets one into
trouble and i
occasionally like to avoid that right
thanks andrea okay next up we've got
claire
cushman claire go ahead
hi um thanks for taking my question um
i'm claire i'm a rising junior in the
college studying psychology and
economics
and i'm zooming in from the boston area
so my question is can you outline some
of the reasons
from your perspective and expertise as
to why the coven-19 pandemic has
disproportionately affected poor
communities and communities of color
and more importantly explain what the
federal government should do to mitigate
these inequalities
especially in the event of another
global health crisis in the future
yeah well great question i'm glad i'm
glad you asked it because i was hoping
someone would ask it
so if you look at minorities communities
that's african-american latinx in some
respects
native americans and alaskan americans
um there are two areas in which they
find themselves disadvantaged
the first though one like does not like
to generalize
but as a general demographic group
minorities fi find themselves because of
their economic
and employment situations in a situation
where it's less easy for them to protect
themselves from getting infected
they have less of a chance of sitting in
front of a computer
teleworking as opposed to being outside
with jobs that require exposure
so their chances of getting infected
are greater than the general population
that's disadvantage number one
disadvantage number two
is when they do get infected
given the social determinants of
medicine that have been around for so
long
they have a much greater incidence and
prevalence
of comorbidities which lead to a poorer
outcome
diabetes hypertension
obesity cardiovascular disease
those kinds of things which put them in
a higher risk
category so it's what we call a double
negative whammy that they get what can
we do now
and what can we do in the long run what
we can do now
is concentrate resources in the
areas where they are demographically
over-represented so that they could have
easy access to testing
better access to health care so that if
and when they do get infected
they can get into proper care early
enough
to maybe mitigate some of the negative
consequences that we can do now
the longer range is do we have a
commitment which i hope we do
to eliminate health disparities which is
a
decade-long commitment you're not going
to do that
overnight there are so many things that
you can do
to modify the reasons why
they have more hypertension they have
more diabetes
they have more obesity so we can do
stuff now
and we can make a commitment to do
things in the long run
thanks claire okay next up we've got
dominic gordon dominic introduce
yourself
hello my name is dominic gordon and i'm
a a freshman in the school of foreign
service i'm just going to enter my
freshman year this year
now i know it's some boring things about
foreign policy
because school foreign service but i had
a question about how
uh how we can how international
relations affects our ability to contain
pandemics
and how greater cooperation amongst
nations could
help us prevent a second pandemic or a
future incident that was that was my
question and thank you for your service
doctor anthony fauci
i you don't know how amazing this is to
speak to you
well it's my pleasure it's it's nice to
speak to you dominic
uh so you you really bring up a very
important
point uh the word pandemic
almost answers your question because
pandemic
means all so it is essentially
is global so if you're going to talk
about
identifying responding to
and containing pandemics you've got to
think globally
you can't think in a vacuum of your own
country
so international relationships trust
between
countries transparency
agreements to have things like global
health security network which we try to
have
those are all critical to an adequate
response
and we have so many examples of when
those things were not
optimal that our response
was slowed and we could have done better
so you know i mean in the issue i've had
a couple of students
who are involved in studies of foreign
service
i mean if there is anything of a
challenge
that requires international cooperation
it's a pandemic by the very definition
of what a pandemic
is all right dominic thanks for the
question and welcome to georgetown
uh all right next up we've got hunter
congdon hunter
um hi my name is hunter kongan i'm
a rising senior in the sfs at georgetown
and i'm
currently in new haven connecticut
my question is um it seems
like we still don't know whether having
had the virus confers immunity
uh when will we find out that
for sure and will the answer that
question affect the vaccine
and could it mean you get more sick if
you get the virus a second time
okay good good good questions hunter so
we will not have the definitive answer
to your question until we're out many
months and a year or more
to be able to definitively determine the
durability
i think i could say with a degree of
confidence
that if you get infected and you recover
it was because your immune
system and your immune response
suppressed
and ultimately eliminated the virus so
if you were infected
i could say confidently that you have
immunity
what i can't tell you is how long that
immunity is going to last
i would hope that it lasts a substantial
period of time
but we don't know because we've only
been involved in this outbreak
for five and a half to six months
does that impact vaccination it does
so what we're going to do is hope that
when we do vaccinate
individuals that the vaccine would give
protection that's at least long enough
for one full
seasonal cycle hopefully much more
but if it isn't there's always the
opportunity to give someone a booster
so that's the answer to your first two
questions
the third question is that if you
get infected before and then get
infected again could it make it worse
you're talking about
what they called enhancement that's
antibody induced
that's a phenomenon that we're studying
now i don't
think i hope it won't be a big deal
there are some
infections where pre-existing
low-level inadequate immunity leads to
an enhancement of infection we've seen
that
with respiratory syncytial virus vaccine
with
dengue and we hope we don't see it
with covet but that's the reason why
when you do a vaccine trial
you pay a lot of attention to safety so
three good questions thanks
all right thanks hunter next up uh april
leonhardt
introduce yourself hi dr bauci my name
is april linhard i'm a graduate student
at ssp
thank you so much for being here today
and discussing all these things with us
my question for you was in a very
contentious type of political climate
how do you
bridge that divide between on the one
hand the necessity to
disseminate critical information about
the seriousness of a disease
and on the other hand the need for that
advice to actually
be accepted on both sides yeah
well the most important thing to do
is when you're dealing in what i think
you're referring to as a divisive
atmosphere uh in the country at whatever
level
you call it is to stick to the science
and stick to the evidence and avoid
at all costs getting involved in any
of the political ideological
divisiveness if you want to get a
message across
build up the confidence in others that
you are speaking
the truth and you are speaking and
advising on the basis of evidence
and science because that's the thing
that's
clean and crystal clear there's not
you know ideology involved there's
there's not
political persuasion involved just stick
with the data
and use that to make whatever advice or
recommendation
you're gonna do and you can get past all
of the other stuff
that's unfortunately background noise
and often gets in the way of what you're
trying to do
okay thanks april uh next let's go
to andrew bialik andrew go ahead and
introduce yourself
good afternoon dr fauci thank you for
being here my name is andrew bilik i'm a
rising junior in the college
studying government i am from long
island new york
um and my question has to do with a lot
of the work that i do
with the georgetown disability alliance
and mental health
how do people around the world
specifically students and parents with
little children reconcile the mental
health
component of going out and leaving
quarantine
and isolation with the risks that it
might necessarily bring along with
it yeah well that's really a great
question andrew i'm glad you asked it
that is one of the reasons why
it it's a complicated situation
you know we we need to contain the
outbreak
and the kinds of confinements and
physical distancing
shutting down if you will have played an
important successful
role in getting cases down
but the reason why it's important
to open the country again
and to try to get back to some degree of
normality
it's not only because of the
inconvenience it's not only because of
the economic impact people losing their
jobs
but what you're talking about and what
you're interested in
it's also important the strain
on the morale and the mental health of
people being put
in a really abnormal situation
like lockdown is one of the things that
you need to consider
and balance so you don't want to open up
and
create a big surge again that would
cause you to take a step backwards but
on the other hand
you've always got to try in a good
prudent
careful way to get back to some form of
normality
one reason of which is the point that
you make it does have
a negative impact on everything
from the health of kids getting checkups
to mental health in general
so that's one of the things that we do
consider so thanks for that question
all right thanks andrew all right next
up we've got quentin quinton go ahead
and introduce yourself
hi dr fauci i'm a rising senior in
georgetown college i'm also working as a
contact tracer this summer and
i was wondering um what steps should
policymakers consider
to ensure that which country and which
groups within that country
get a deployable and effective vaccine
first but this does not magnify
existing social and geopolitical
inequalities
thank you well quentin thank you for
being a contact tracer
i i i applaud you for that we need you
um the idea about equities
uh not only in the distribution of
vaccines and scarce therapies but also
in the clinical trials that determine if
they work or not
you want equitable distribution because
you want to make sure
that when you test something it is safe
and effective
in a minority as well as it is in
the majority of people we have
mechanisms of doing that
we have outreach in the community we
have community engagement
and we have a number of mechanisms
of getting people together clinical
trials
community reps and ethicists to make
sure
that well first of all i hope and i
think we will have enough
for everyone who needs it but as it's
being rolled out
you often have to make a choice of who
gets it first
a general principle though i will still
leave it up to the discussions
of the ethicists and others is to give
it to those
who are most vulnerable and who would
most benefit
benefit from it such as first responders
health care providers essential members
of society
people with underlying conditions
hopefully you could quickly
get everybody vaccinated or get the
therapy to everybody who needs it
but sometimes you have to make difficult
decisions
that's the reason why you want to go by
the strongest medical and ethical
principles to guide you
tony just just a quick follow-up could
you just give us a couple sentences
on the state of vaccine development just
your projection
given where we are right now when we're
likely to have
vaccines obviously there's nothing
guaranteed but your your sense of the
likely timeline
well we're on a good track john with
some good news that's either coming out
today or tomorrow
the publication of the phase one trial
for one of those
candidates that showed really good
neutralizing antibodies
safe no adverse events but good levels
of neutralizing antibodies in the
vaccine
that's going to go into phase three at
the end of this month at the end of july
then there are other candidates that
will soon be following
at the end of the summer the early fall
mid-fall
so i think we're in a pretty good place
when it comes to vaccines
i mean obviously you want to prove that
it's safe and this effective
but if things work out the way we hope
they do i think by the end of this
year and the beginning of calendar year
2021
we will have enough information to know
whether the candidates that we're
dealing with
are safe and effective and hopefully
apropos of quentin's question
will be able to distribute it in a
equitable manner
to a large number of people so i'm
cautiously quite optimistic about that
great thank you tom thanks and thanks to
quentin for that for the question
uh all right next up dan saks go ahead
hi um i'm dan sacks i'm an incoming
first year at the college and i'll be
studying linguistics
um and so my answer to my the question i
had was answered a little bit but i
wanted to take it to
um about the vaccines uh when will it be
released across the country and across
the globe and when do we when should we
expect
arguably few infections on the berkeley
campus up until
about 10 days ago when we did have a
cluster of cases
apparently linked to
students primarily attending a social
function
at a fraternity house or actually
probably a couple of different parties
it clearly reinforces what many people
already knew
which is that this is not going to be
easy and they're changing the behaviors
of large numbers of young
generally healthy people is going to be
very difficult
[Music]
we believe that it is the hong kong
government the police
that should be put on trial and will be
put on trial
because of that suppression of our right
to mourn
june 4 our right to uh assembly
for the candlelight vigil which have
been going on for 30 years
and the 31st year they ban our gathering
under the name of public order ordinance
this is a complete denial of our rights
under the constitution basic law
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
guys
okay so as long as we got both cameras
the cuts you got those 201 202 with the
cuts
you're not going to have control we'll
have to fix that another time
you've got a 200 camera
uh
welcome
all right
yes
oh
jason
good
uh
are you panned in the center to both
okay
well he's only sending me one channel so
he's just sending me a mix of the pool
and everything so it's i'm only i'm
giving them one channel my other channel
is just on camera mic
are you worried about jim where are you
tim the network said that there are only
one back well if he's only sent he's
only sending me the one channel i'm not
getting one on one and two so it's only
gonna feed back
yeah he's sending 12 channels
if you want to put that one up just so
they see that there's a second channel
coming
i got them both right now
okay so he has this
okay so we are sending the one line of
audio via pool
and then when person comes down
audio coming in as well but everything
is all
mixed through one line
hey
cameraman on this camera
oh
basically through this mold i should be
able to just plug it into the camera
you know but normally they always have
to go through
and then you're gonna send it back
oh
thank you
okay
foreign